les amis bonsoir ou bonjour j'espère
bonsoir pour vous ai bien peur et
bienvenue dans ce dernier épisode daoud
classe mon gars on va enfin savoir où
ils line
qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé qu est ce
qui est arrivé à joystiq et aussi dans
le passé c'est parti oh là là mais quel
un truc c'est bien observer ou été
suspendu à ce rebond et il faudrait
qu'on est con me semble je sais pas
comment faire ah voilà ok j'ai trouvé
incroyable il peut toujours du sort
voilà une météo très peu charmante la
gorge et j'ai goal mais pas trop où
j'allais dire une blague mais du coup
j'ai plutôt envie avec cette sportive
tout seul ça me pue tout envie vraiment
n'a pas envie de rigoler c'est fini donc
je saute en face à ces horribles à part
dans mon dos bouge comme i thought of
time it what what
mais c'est quoi cette mini porte cm une
porte sa peau que j'habite choqué
roptin mais je suis encore dans ces
endroits mais non c'est rempli de déré
de salles hérétiques qui me
justement peur
oh [ __ ] aux mecs ça fait un max de
bruit
là ça va chez moi là dedans fin j'étais
très fatigué dans l'épisode sac
donc j'étais vraiment je flippais pour
rien là ça va un peu mieux en vrai je
prends du recul par rapport aux choses
par rapport à ma vie oh [ __ ] de merde
mais merde
les gars vous n'êtes pas cool mais merde
on mais merde ah ouais bah ouais elle
mieux tomber de cheval gp10 recul sur ma
vie donc ça va aller mieux
[Applaudissements]
je rope je pouvais me laisser tranquille
genre minutes yoplait une minute le
temps je me soigne non c'est bon on peut
plus clair
[Applaudissements]
on y va on y va on y va on va aller et
là on va rater dans le pit heures
d'école futur hertz a annoncé pose
entièrement faux c'est quoi ça à terme
la photo
alors on se soigne on se bat sur le bras
gauche vous êtes on peut avoir bloqué
sur ça c'est vrai que ses parents le box
le mal partout mais souhaite qu'elle
bras gauche ok on y va avec fera monter
haut
ohlala pourquoi il y avait deux barrages
dans le coup mais je crois qu'on n'avait
jamais vu ça encore de tous le jours n'a
jamais vu ça pas forcément bon signe
comme ça ils arrivent à le télésiège la
cabine
bow wow mais c'est tout la non pardon
l'aja bon j'avoue là j'ai pas fait assez
le point sur ma vie je te plaît assez de
recul les fichiers dessus allez on y va
on y va
c'est parti ah merde alors on y va on y
va on n'a pas peur on n'a pas peur
laissez nous tranquilles livre seul
homme
dès que sur les mines pour te quoi
direction et ses recherches quoi vous
attendez vous du coup de bâton n'est en
fait là
je suis dans la villa à aa1 [ __ ] mais
il fait qu en plein milieu hui ho [ __ ]
mais même si je suis revenu au début
[Applaudissements]
ça dégage
ça dégage c'est le même mec qui doublait
la voie des monstres que le nain sur son
sur sa monture c'est le même grain de
voix [ __ ] voit la petite anecdote nul
1-1 à balayer les mines
[ __ ] voilà on y est vraiment ce widget
c'est fini mais quand c'est là où tu en
es it up the game t'avoir que l'on
s'enfonce mec va bien pouvoir rien faire
son nez dans le caca
alors qui sont les gens des mines est ce
que ce sont des gens charmants
[Applaudissements]
ah ah ah
ni mon amour j'arrive
le mec est mort dix fois normand way en
vrai [ __ ] encore ça va encore se
mettre à l'eau redescende d'un coup non
c'est bon rythme
mais je fais de la merde que tu sais tu
préfères assiste à ok [ __ ] alors on a
quoi ababord passer en dessous comme ça
et hop là voilà mais moi on est en bas
mais qu on applique à escalader la
petite voiture
saloperie pts à l'escrimeur à audio quoi
bon des bons drops hutin les dans les
mines mecs sont tissés poultry hockey et
ben welcome to the home in a while font
péter des fonds pts et 4 les lapierre
donc dominé si ça existe vraiment ce
délire là oh [ __ ] my bad jeu faut
toujours suivre le monstre
où aller je suis juste une page chapitre
oh mon dieu le fruit de la destruction
de la mairie dans les entrailles fétide
de la mer martyrs ok ok ok
wahou d'accord c'est un mec entend se
faire manger par des verts très bien
donc ne jamais suivre les monstres
obinna là il t'amène devant des cadavres
j'arrive les jarres yvelines j'arrive
les joues la [ __ ] j'y arrive l'été
avec lui trop donc je descende encore
plus mais non mais pire idée maintenant
maintenant j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive
j'arrive jacques non juste n'en arrête
arrête ça mon la pire phrase que j'ai
entendu de ma vie tu n'es pas méchant
blé mais juste désorientés
haïti noter le médiator ah bon ça qu'ils
n'aiment pas
[Applaudissements]
tm et moi ça veut dire que c'est bloqué
il y avait encore un [ __ ] de mai quand
foetus enchaîné le sait ça me rend à
fabas faut remonter du coup qu'on a
vendu plus de pistes en façon je vais
pas te mentir à à peu prendre à gauche
ou à droite à droite et encore un foetus
hard
ils sont fait qu ici n'ont pas vécu je
te fais trouver ligne
j'espérais une plaque bon ça c'est très
possible j'aimerais avoir c'est à quel
moment de l'histoire il est en train de
commenter les vidéos qu'il a prises en
fait c'est quand c'est le cas ça aulas
ils sont fait exploser
c est ce que ça va être la fin de
justement ça va être ça ou chez ba a
apparemment là on a un petit trou
heureusement que les gens qui prennent
ces chemins avant nous saignent
énormément ça nous permet vraiment de
trouver facilement le chemin à prendre
c'est vrai nom si les pâtures et qu'on
n'aurait jamais trouvé au aux [ __ ]
avec qui est mort noyé juste là que
j'arrivais n'a je prends un peu mon
temps je suis désolé ok et là c'est quoi
s'appuyer du monde ouvert sa plante
à votre avis qui a été bien oui et bien
raison
l appétit je l'avais totalement dit et
là le truc c'est qu'il va falloir aller
là où le monstre est apparue parce que
c'est toujours comme ça et vous le savez
mieux que moi a well as un cul-de-sac de
mort est vraiment allé là-bas quoi aller
plus loin là on va garder notre sprint
au cas où nous lis manukura après tout
c'est exactement comme la exactement
comme la mecs acteurs ok ça
[Musique]
je suis dans la merde je suis dans la
merde à plus totale je ne la mer est
totale de la mer la plus totale je vois
pas de la station essence hyper marrant
hop là revient là on était le truc bien
nulle beaux mecs faut y aller un moment
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'est bon chemin sa relégation
monsieur c'est bon chemin oui bon j'ai
la vidéo dans le doute et cory avec les
morts
je regardais ces visages à la recherche
de lignes à la recherche du mieux pour
jessica rip à temps mais le mec j'ai ce
qui en fait c'était l'amour de ta vie tu
terre-battue sur l'île quoi maestro
bizarre comme il parle pas de chaque
côté à droite j'ai compris j'ai compris
[ __ ] on redescend
oui je perds x ouverte si c'était pas
ouvert mais correct et marange annonces
ont été foutu on était des death by day
like compris aux mots exceptionnel alors
on y va on a fait clairement mais qu'il
faut y aller et bah oui on sait qu'il
faut monter à la droite
voilà il faut le faire sortir jusque là
bas
ok et maintenant et alors par là ok il
ya un aiguillage et un aiguillage
j'ai compris allez allez ça va sûrement
encore je suis foutu là je peux rien
faire
ok c'est fait ah le petit trou mon pote
yates thème est on est bien je dis
arrêtez avec ce mec arrête une foule
kfor voilées ou là n'ont clairement pas
ouais là bas voyez une page et un mort
en brochets chef 14 et dans les mois qui
précèdent sa naissance l'antéchrist
surveillera dans les entrailles de sa
mère et son malheur et la misère
saignerons camp pour l'inter d'accord
d'accord d'accord d'accord
l'hymne mon amour là je commence à
craquer tout logiquement moins bon
j'annonce ai vraiment marre il faut
aller où la part le titre ab oui mais qu
au final [ __ ] mais il faudrait qu'on
soit aujourd'hui pour trouver une pile
dans cette [ __ ] de mines quoi
qu'est-ce que ça foutrait l'a réellement
vous en faites pas d'argent n'est encore
en stock temps il fait tout péter en
rien ok on y va waouh sa sentence fi des
ouf
oh non attends je recherche avant de
nous contrairement au hockey
alors les casques ouais bon ballon et
mecha ce temps là il est temps de voir
ligne vraiment non [ __ ]
ce que vous voyez petit lieu s'amenait
de la maison ils venaient de là je
pouvais déjà les entendre je savais pas
si c'était réel j'ai vu le squelette du
foetus au fond de sa cage thoracique
what the fuck line tu veux mon bébé
j'aimerais tellement de retrouver ça
fait un an que je joue dans ce but
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] au plus tard étaient alors des
créatures d'appui ti
je veux sentir ta faim je veux voir en
vrai visage
la semence va brûler ce monde
rené le lamer
mathaf besoin d'heures je me réjouis de
notre seigneur enfants nus qui ne cache
rien je réponds dire sa masse que je
montrais visages autour moi tout voir
ans
[Musique]
à
ok ben amos au [ __ ] même qu après la
[ __ ]
oh my gosh led ce drame
[Applaudissements]
alors merde sur votre chance
what c'est la fin pour moi a lancé m
elle me suis toujours je l'entends
j'annonce pas vous le dire je vais à
trois avec vous arrêter vous coûter le
cap a abaissé par oh [ __ ] c'est un
vrai labyrinthe place est au départ la
limite c'est pas par là c'est pas du
tout par là qui a dicté par là enfin en
vrai c'est par là sur lequel vous à kiev
l'eau on va falloir faire la braye comme
ça la brenva en avril mais en fait non
on lui a pas laissé le temps de faire le
tour
faut lui laisser le temps de venir voilà
et maintenant on y va
et là on la brein est hyper malin à les
remonter sur fast à un moment aussi
ok la fois les par la haye m courteille
l'appui il ya plus de souffle qu'on
court plus tard moi ça me rend au genre
t'es souper danse pour la mecque de soi
je te jure t sprint infinie mon pote la
stamina sexe de plus pour toi même
attention
non bon j'ai une telle nouvelle à vous
annoncer mais en fait on est pas du tout
là bas que j'ai j'ai condamné la porte
et tout mais pour rien oui avec ça mais
nulle part [ __ ] non c'est exceptionnel
on est vraiment des kaka et ciel et
l'amex la forme les futurs attendus
monde et je pense qu'elle va être là
ouais ben regarde
ouais la meuf elle campe un ll zone à un
vrai faux qu'on meure je suis désolé
mais après faut qu'on aille les résidus
non tu ne s'en sortira pas
[Applaudissements]
il ya des espèces de away voilà abonnés
l'umami pris dans un cul-de-sac à balma
bien défoncé le cul clairement en fait
il faut faire comme ce qu'on avait fait
on avait été définie sur ce move
incroyable qu'on l'a esquivée permet dé
fallait pas du tout aller dans la pièce
où j'étais ça c'est vraiment pour les
coûts et vu que je suis con je suis
tombé en plein dedans à intensité ou
déjà mais sur un prix là il ya un
passage déjà il faudra aller à voile à
celle là je crois qu'elle arrive de là
souvenez vous dans un mois la l2 là on
la voit il ya des flammes là bas le mur
comment ça voilà il arrive quand elles
passent faut qu'on passe là sous l'eau
comme prévu à lélex sa couronne de
brindilles très belle couronne la
fouille à l'est
elle remonte ici il ya un panneau activé
en fait que je n'avais pas vu voilà qui
est en fait la pièce et pour te cacher
celle de grille mais c'est pas du tout
pour y aller sans rien y faire ici il ya
un mode panneaux j'ai vu juste avant de
mourir
moi je suis mort de trois points
j'annonce et là aussi il faut y
retourner à l'esquivé vous en faites pas
on est où là
[ __ ] ok c'est là à gauche
ok nickel on l'a fait les gars [ __ ] ok
là faut sauter iolo a atteint avec ses
débuts les deux fois ci la [ __ ] quel
con alors même qu'on va peut-être trouvé
l'une un jour quoi ce serait bien
franchement je commence à être long là
en vrai ce qu'on n'a pas une pub parce
que franchement un jour ou l'autre on va
manquer depuis le ca 9 à 7 tev
alors qui est un instrument là
ok j'ai compris aiguillages qu'est ce
que tu fais
j'ai rien fait moi jusqu'à stories dit
toi qui es tu lui as fait c'est toi ok
on y va
vim
oh là là là là j'en peux plus des
visions mec gauche tout droit d'asie
tout droit ok la réponse était rapide ok
échelle
[ __ ] mais mais qu'un jour là il faut
qu'on voit lille mais vraiment j'en peux
plus je trouve ça un peu le lot en vrai
de revoir l'insee vraiment [ __ ] tout
je sais du hide and seek oh merde h que
c'est ma pote au shit
ok bon allez laisse morales morlaix ce
malaise dans l'espace laisse moi
ah ouais on me suivre ça il ya des
flammes derrière ça me suis dit on va
pas se mentir ça fait pas semblant à je
suis épuisé est ce que c'est le monde
est épuisé
est ce que vraiment le moment est
propice à l'épuisement aux maires de
gauche ou droite vas-y droite
[Applaudissements]
ohlala mais non
et juste derrière
oh non j'ai pu la ce moment là c'est
sérieusement hockey lac en face de la
merde je savais que j'ai une grande
faiblesse aux abords du hockey fait dans
la lumière harry's light and most
ailleurs fou aux [ __ ] s'est plaint
des rites x est en train de tomber mec
c'est sur moi que j'aille là
[Applaudissements]
un [ __ ] c'était par la voilà je suis
obstinée à me dire non c'est pas par là
c'est faux pourquoi il clignote vers mon
écran la cua a aucune échelle c'est bon
j'ai cru que je m'étais je m'était
totalement fail mais on est bon elle
reçoit et dans l'histoire nous a trouvé
une pile mon gars et ça ça ça nous a mis
très très bien ce qu'ils allaient pilon
les consommer une vitesse mon gars fait
tellement sombre et tout temps et la
camaro verte
bon ce qu'on va revoir un jour notre
amie line
notre famille est ce que du coup on
sortira sera à la base on était là pour
faire un documentaire sur une fille
retrouvée morte étranglée sur la route
enceinte à la fille du de deux premières
mais souvenez-vous qui se fait tuer au
bout d'une minute d'amitié c'était bon
ah ouais bon bah mec est ok
oh là là faut arrêter simple du co2 mais
un peu patrie désolé
l'ajustement la crise des publics bon ok
dessus
ok on va recharger parce qu'on a en plus
de pulls j'ai pas quand il nous en reste
l'ancien il faudra être prudent
sauvegarde à samba bossa connais bien ok
ok à une page mon dieu je ne l'avais pas
vu chapitre u15 et dieu pris la parole
par la bouche et ezequiel et ses
oreilles seigneur cédant se brisèrent il
faut arrêter il fera arrêter j'ai joué
je les une phrase mais au bout d'une
phrase je suis convaincu qu il faudra
tenir ça aurait été des bruits est-ce
que céder
poison il dit mais non elle a pris un
canard mais au calme c'est pas normal
déjà quand tu pocket que tu voles
quelqu'un comme ça à l'arraché tu lui
souffle pas du pollen relève le défi on
commence on s'est un peu moins c'est un
peu limite comme manière de faire oh
serait ce la fin du jeu
ton père le christ est méritant regrets
si l'autre mais pas soufflé de la
cauquenne d'emmener je me devais de
venir plus vite
j'avoue c'est joe cole à la ola vite mec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
j'écoutais les fidjiens [ __ ] sont
mignons cbc la mer cette joie fait
tellement plaisir
ok mais tu dois abandonner si tu dis que
j'ai gagné se lâcheraient
mais tu dois le dire c'est tout tu m'as
lieux tels chiffres
vilaine va automatiquement le butin aux
agents on sortait vraiment ensemble mais
je laisse en fait il était vraiment avec
du ski à la base en fait
sallèles situé salle a traumatisé à vie
et je pense qu'on va voir l'histoire de
ce tu vois là j'en ai les endroits on
n'a pas le droit d'être va me tomber
dessus à pitre je ne sais pas pourquoi
tu fais autant de mystères est ce que
demander mieux comme on dit j'ai demandé
la première alors j'en sais rien la
ferme c'est toi
tu peux me demander de mon école d'art
d'être je sais rien je voulais juste
savoir
toi aussi tu es nul je sèche et commence
à fait pas des mecs d'être dans cette
école là après tout tous les visions
qu'on a eu un mec c'est l'horreur
qu'est ce qu'il fout tout cela ce temps
là les éléments pour la vue
tu crois que les parents sont rentrés à
la maison
non d'habitude ils rendent rappelle
dîner tu penses que je pourrais venir
chez toi oui bien sûr et oui bien sûr
pourquoi pourquoi pas mais pourquoi tu
veux venir chez moi je sais pas c'est
mignon
c'est tellement maignan aya débrouillent
pas à droite
qu'est-ce que tu ne sais pas de jessica
désolé qu'est ce que vous faites ici
tous les deux je suis désolé pour le
thermique
nous sommes restés après l'école pour la
revue et nous allons partir retournent
en classe
s'il vous plaît clic tu n'as pas encore
d'ennui blake tu ne veux pas te dirait
des ennuis quand même resté avec moi
[ __ ] je veux que vous disiez ce que
vous faisiez ici vous conduisiez vont
mal
dois-je appeler vos parents jessica
secousse doit ramer je vous en prie je
veux juste que nous soyons amis personne
n'a d'ennuis pour le moment l'un de vous
deux pense pouvoir faire ce qu'il faut
jessica jessica regarde-moi veux-tu pris
avec moi tu veut m'aider à faire ce
qu'ils font n'est ce pas
et si tu rentres chez toi à bloc et j'ai
interrompu quelque chose entre ça alors
tu voulais quoi tu ne veux rien dire
vous savez
on est un don de dieu pour reconnaître
le bien du mal est ce que tu veux très
mal
rentre chez toi et prix j'ai fait du
reste flexible m cette situation assez
durs et il n'y a pas de problème mais tu
dois nous laisser tout va bien tu peux
partir jeune homme allait par
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] mec hockey tellement bas
dans très bas dans mon gars c'est juste
pas croyable ce grand couloir et tous
les casiers qui est de retour à putte
h&m pas quoi dire tellement je trouve ça
ignoble quoi les horribles [ __ ] mais
qu'il est horrible quoique même sa voix
ils l'ont trop bien choisi quoi le
doubleur il le cache
[Musique]
je ne sais pas ce que j'ai cru voir
[Applaudissements]
temps frais
mais vous avez démarré mais là je n'ai
pas approuvé à la mecque du pin up a été
carrément venerque or up est un mec
cette cinématique incroyable tu n'as pas
c'est mon bien peu les familles et tout
a donc loire le faire du but a juste
pris le temps de le voir la suivre et on
put 1a le fils de [ __ ] pardon ça
m'échappe effet que je le dise falala
terriblement aulas on est ou non en
enfer va clairement c'est l'enfer
thiais
tâche content que on voit enfin tout ça
quoi enfin content je suis triste de
découvrir ce qui s'est passé je suis
content d'eux dans pas après cinq heures
de jeu avoir les réponses à nos
questions quoi ces plaisirs céline est
enceinte
comment peux tu être anciens supplie je
veux pas mourir ici je vais pas qu'une
autre bébés meurent ici
mais moi je laisserais pas de tuer faut
qu'on se casse ou comme au début je
crois qu'on doit sortir de là
on est sorti je fais sortie artistique
heures il faisait froid mais la neige
commençait juste à tomber
on va trouver un adulte et mériter ce
qui m'arrivait tout ira mieux
ce n'est pas ma faute et il tape des
phases mongai devient ouais c'est celui
qui se lève
lle enfin vous étiez noah à vous
demander pourquoi faisait tout ennui
parce qu'en fait on vient vraiment de
vivre une nuit ces genres six heures de
jeu c'était vraiment la nuit l'avion
s'est crashé à minuit là il est 6 heures
du mat donc le soleil commence enfin à
se lever et c'est pas pour nous déplaire
alors va s'en sortir les bois sur le
soleil comme au début je cois
ça valait une savane et ça va aller
c'est quoi quoi
oui moi y'a du tout ouais ça va aller
lille courage courage ça va aller ça va
aller ça va aller en fait pas
on va être bien on ira à l'hôpital de
symboles et les trous pour accoucher ne
t'en fais pas c'est trop dangereux
tu peux pas ok ok fais attention je suis
désolé tiens tiens accouchement du monde
très clairement on est atteint mais lady
mond abala matelas tient met toi bien ok
gauthier au [ __ ] mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fait là sa maison à saint lô
[ __ ] elle était là ça va aller ça va
aller mais ça va aller mais si tout va
bien tout va bien ça va aller ça va
aller
[Applaudissements]
on va envahir le genre matin j'ai juste
là il ya une notion unique qui va
instituer le bébé sont calmes
ça va aller ça va des savanes
tu vas tu allongé là on peut pas c'est
une blague c'est là qu'on peut pas
[ __ ] mais c'est la motte avec cette
[ __ ] d'arbres l'a peut-être nous a
tués ici surtout avec y avait son arme
posée contre avenir je n'ai pas quitté
qui abat la semaine
[Applaudissements]
havas a frappé par l'orage
oh ouais c'est bien fait ça très bien
dit attends c'est dieu qui a envoyé le g
pablo l'a transpercée ou quoi pas une
croix l'a transpercée bon gars
incroyable bon bah salut ma faim c'est
un plaisir très reconnu jeta aux
attentes de voir mourir
y a pas de chemin en fait
enfin dans une forêt et tout part en
couilles tu peux voir ça va aller ça
valait savage toit pourrait trouver un
abri est inquiète ouais c
des mythes
on passe dans les flammes auraient fait
retour mais il n'avait aucun sens si
c'est possible absence
soleil bientôt fin du monde
à sète déluge
[Musique]
non j'appelle aussi réfugiés c'est ce
qu'on va faire
alex en france on pense on line
beauchamp c'est très très beau c'est
petit effet ça me fait carrément qui
fait
et les femmes aussi
allez continuer
on peut le faire on y est on dit au
journal
la tempête en cuir d'avoir fait ça sur
le bord du jeu par l'inrs alors je dois
partir de la terre ou averses allamano
qu il allait il faut au moins un matelas
à quoi un truc la montre et les noirs
chez pas moi on y est csc encore la
maison il ya d'un mec vraiment c'est on
n'a pas de chance
ok ok au [ __ ] mais c'est là où l'hôtel
stérols à la séquence était réfugié bah
ouais le mec avec sa roue derrière et où
aulas là tu peux le faire
qu'est-ce qui va pas du tout inspiré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si non ils n'ont cancer du sein cancer
du tout ah non c'est déprimant
non non
[Applaudissements]
non plus que notre il arrivait assez le
congo y avait pas de temps dans un
véhicule pas encore l'histoire
la pièce de théâtre on garde ça pour le
jour j
c'est vrai ok on se fait la bise comme
ça c'est ta copine dis le moi cela sinon
quoi ok j'étais encore eu
c'est l'enfant naisse 30 d'enseignants
ça
approche
famille d'egypte
m
vous avez tati sable simulée de pratique
monsieur silence hymne
une attendaient la naissance
devant dieu lui-même et tous ces anges
jeu je les aie
j'ai haï le seigneur notre dieu chutent
chacun entre n'est pas deux fois fait et
dieu est toujours
silencieux
tu cet enfant 7 juin
si tu as quelques amours que ce soit des
grâces sous ta boite je sais que dieu
nous temps par les ports et j'attends de
lui tu ne leur répondent
d'accord allons nous en dit [ __ ] tout
ça pour ça que ça faisait cinq heures
[ __ ] c'est horrible je suis pas comblé
mais qui a passé la nuit à rechercher le
vécu les pires trucs et il te retrouves
il il a son gosse toi tu meurs quoi
[ __ ] ça fait plaisir qu'il fasse jour
mec c'est trop plaisir incroyable
à
c'est la femme du joueur
fini [ __ ]
jusqu'au bout quoi
voilà
et
ça va la musique
c'est fait mourir le contraste entre le
décor est ta merde
le contraste entre le décor à la musique
c'est n'importe quoi ils ont fait une
soirée d'accord
c'est le casier non
[Musique]
obama
oh
ne t'inquiète pas jamais je n'aurais
jamais dû le tuer
et si c'était pas de lumière sauveur
écoute ma prière je t'en prie seigneur
veille sur moi et doucement m'envoie
dans le sommeil toi qui vois tout mon
dieu lave tout ce que j'ai pu faire
d'odieux elle moi de venir chaque jour
plus sains et ainsi vivre dans ton amour
zii end eh ben les amis n'hésitez pas à
aimer ce dernier épisode s'il vous a plu
ici toute la série vous a plu si vous
avez aimé ce que l'espèce était ouf
[ __ ] enfin on a on a vu la franco à la
fin du jeu en fait c'est marrant parce
qu à la fin on est presque plus
intéressé par n'est plus intéressé par
ce que par le passé du mec son histoire
avec jessica que par la situation
actuelle où il est dans un cosec touya
link et on sait pas où
du coup c'était bel et bien l'hypothèse
du prêtre pédophile tard est absolument
ignobles c'était un très bon jeu je
trouve qu'il ya une heure de jeu en trop
bizarrement normandie toujours l'inversé
je trouve ça vraiment une heure de jeu
entre où séjourne la poursuite du gie
actifs gesci je me cacherais active mais
l'histoire est vraiment sympa les décors
sont vraiment époustouflant le
franchement bravo raid barrès voilà
maintenant on n'aura plus jamais peur
mais juste s'amuser rigoler un peu et
décompresser à lui à savoir garder at
les prochaines vidéos au revoir les amis
[Musique]